you would hire like sisters
i like twins when it comes to twins on
tv
not everyone can do it for real like
mary kate and ashley or cole and dylan
sprouse
in fact more often than not one actor is
given the enormous
task of playing each twin or in the case
of nina dobrev on the vampire diaries
like
a hundred different people we're
checking out some of the most amazing
scenes
featuring on-screen twins that you'd
never know were played by a single
person
wow we're identical we can't think of a
better way to get started than the one
the only lindsay lohan and her iconic
roles
as annie and halle in the parent trap
the parent trap was filmed long before
cgi was an everyday occurrence in
hollywood so they used a ton of
old-school techniques to pull off
lohan's most twinning moments
to make it look like there were two of
them they would film all of lohan's
scenes twice
having her jump back and forth between
characters don't you see it
see what the resemblance between us
lohan would have the chance to play
twins once more
in the far darker far creepier movie i
know who killed me
about a young woman who is so connected
with her long-lost twin that she can
feel everything that happens to her
the 2018 comedy thriller a simple favor
was chock full of twists and turns
the most exciting of which has got to be
the reveal of blake lively's secret twin
sister played by none other than blake
lively
i thought you were the alpha now i am
the officer
not only did lively have to act opposite
herself
she had to get into a pretty gruesome
underwater fight with her too
all of this was done by having lively
shoot each part of the scene
separately with a body double but she
makes an extremely convincing set of
twins who couldn't be more different
we have the same face yet she's the cute
one
you might be just as surprised as we
were to learn that when dove cameron
first started filming live and maddie
she almost quit the role after the first
season cameron said that was because of
how punishing the schedule was
and for a very young actor we don't
blame her
she had to film everything as live go
back and reshoot all the scenes as
maddie then record all the music on the
weekends and
somehow also try to fit school into the
mix
i i looked at your face and you look
like kathryn i couldn't believe the
resemblance
we can see how hard it would be to play
two characters on the same tv show
but how about well we don't have an
exact number but
it's a lot we're talking of course about
nina dobrev and her many
many characters on vampire diaries she
played doppelgangers
alternate versions of the same character
vampires humans and
everything in between dobrev worked
closely with the costume and the makeup
departments
to make sure that every character she
played was unique
i'm katherine pierce i'm a survivor
one of the biggest reveals in pretty
little liars was the fact that spencer
hastings had a twin sister
i don't even know what question to us
first who are you
really and they didn't even reveal her
until the final episode of the final
season
but troy and bellisario was actually
told about her secret twin all the way
back in 2014.
marlene king the creator of the show
wasn't sure if she wanted to introduce
the twin storyline in the show during
season five
but finally confirmed for bellisario
that she would in fact have to begin
working on the character of alex drake
before season six when actor josh pence
went through a month's worth of rigorous
auditions to finally be cast as one of
the winklevoss twins in david fincher's
the social network
he thought it was going to be his big
break what he didn't know
until he already agreed to do the movie
is that he was going to have his face
and voice completely cgi'd by army
hammer
and disappear completely even after all
that preparation
he claims to have felt more like a body
double than an actor in the movie
but at least david fincher was nice
about it
sarah paulson has played many amazing
characters in her time working with ryan
murphy
but playing conjoined twins bet and dot
in american horror story freak show was
a whole new challenge
it's not every day it comes across two
beauties in one body
the process of creating bet and dot
involved a ton of prosthetics
including an entire prosthetic head that
was used in the wide shots
a green screen head attachment that
could be animated in post
and of course paulson had to do every
scene twice
only an actor of her caliber could pull
off something this
impressive one of the biggest challenges
of playing twins is definitely creating
two distinct characters who don't just
feel like the same person doing
everything twice
mark ruffalo who recently played twin
brothers thomas afflicted with
schizophrenia and dominic
in i know this much is true knows just
how much work goes into it
instead of having him hop in and out of
the makeup chair the filmmakers went a
very different route
they shot all of dominic's scenes in the
first 15 weeks
before ruffalo took five weeks off to
study the mental illness
shave and gain 30 pounds in order to
play thomas
thank you very good brother to me
fight scenes are hard enough with two
actors but when paul rudd had to fight
himself
in living with yourself he said it was
the hardest thing he'd ever had to do
with the help of an amazing stunt team
and a body double
they were able to pull off the
incredible scene but since rudd had to
go back and do it all twice
we can see how he would have been
exhausted is enough to drive anybody
into therapy freddie highmore was only
16 years old when he was cast as twins
in the spiderwick chronicles
a challenge that would make many older
actors nervous he said that the key to
creating the brothers as two
individual people was to really
differentiate their reactions to the
world around them
along with totally distinct costumes and
styling that's really
impossible one actor who had no problem
creating two
wildly different characters was lupita
nyong'o in the jordan peel movie
us the shadow hated the girl
in the time it would normally take her
to prepare for one role
she actually had to learn ballet for
adelaide create the voice for her tether
red
and learn a ton of fight choreography
and when it came time to film
jordan peele warned her just how tiring
it was going to be
and he was right in order for tom hardy
to play two identical twins in legend
the filmmakers went old school and used
the split screen technique
tom's long time stand-in jacob tamori
would act opposite-hearty with his back
to the camera
and had to be incredibly precise about
even the tiniest movements
so that tom could replicate them exactly
later on top of that
hardy only had an hour to switch
characters before doing the scene again
it's unbelievable like the
transformation is ridiculous alice in
wonderland was a very cgi heavy movie
so it wasn't hard to animate matt
lucas's face onto his body double for
him to play both tweedledee
and tweedle dumb but that still meant
that lucas had to go back and redo
every scene so that they could cut and
paste his face on top of the body double
working beside him
tatiana maslany played five main clones
in orphan black but there are up to 14
in total
she collaborated closely with the hair
and makeup team to create individual
looks
and had an on-set dialogue and acting
coach at the ready to give each clone a
distinct voice and character
all of that with only 30 to 45 minutes
to hop in the makeup chair and switch
between characters at any given time
this is what you think i look like yeah
this girl looks nothing like me
and of course we had to end this list
with our favorite tv twins
ever phoebe and ursula from friends
played by the iconic lisa kudrow
little known fact ursula actually
started out as a small
side character on the sitcom mad about
you before kudrow was cast as a lead on
friends
so because she was on two primetime tv
shows at the same time
they brought ursula unto friends to make
things a little less confusing for
viewers
oh i got you a birthday present oh wow
you remembered
if they had never told us they did it
all alone we definitely would have
thought these actors were hiding a
secret twin somewhere
especially blake lively we never saw
that one coming
now don't mind us but we have to go ask
our parents if we ever had an evil twin
who mysteriously
disappeared see you next time